we live in an era of increased
uncertainty
crises and ongoing conflicts a stable
sustainable future sometimes seems out
of reach the university of cambridge
the berlin school of public engagement
and open science
the museum of natural history and the
humble university berlin
have recently launched a joint project
to connect young people
scientists and creatives from all over
the globe
the sustainable futures academy we met
anna ross who did a documentary on the
project in fall
2020. the sustainable futures academy
is basically a very crazy idea to start
with namely to
put together researchers and
young generation gen z as we call them
18 to 25 year olds
with creative professionals to create
science communication and public
engagement output
on the topics of sustainable futures so
we asked all of them to come together
and then in
six groups create sound pieces
digital exhibitions poetry
map making comics it was so interesting
to me that i thought everybody has
different
visions of sustainable futures that's
where there's like
futures and not one future but to me
it's
a fulfillment because it's also a
question about how
we how we feel when we engage in
environmental behaviors and how we
collectively as a future proceed forward
so it's about happiness in a sense and i
think that's ultimately what we're
striving for in a sense it's like the
natural path that we're
eventually as a society going towards
the way the academy was set up it's also
very oh it was very open to grow
with the people that were involved with
it i think that's a central aspect of
the academy that everyone kind of
bought into this idea of we're gonna
participate in something
where we don't know if it's even gonna
work
not only do we not know what's going to
come out of the academy
but if something's going to come out at
all you know
there were so many places where it could
not have worked
but it worked get people from different
walks of life
together to think practically and with
all their knowledge and passion that
they
have of solutions of what can we do what
little things
can we do what systemical things can we
do what can we do together
everything that the participants of the
sustainable futures academy created
will be shown on the berlin science week
so you will be able to
again it's all produced remotely so to
digitally
kind of walk with us through that vision
that all these amazing participants
created
the sustainable futures academy and
the co-creative output can change the
world
by inspiring people to dare to try
something that hasn't been done before
where you don't know if it's going to
work
but to still dare to try and put your
passion
and your knowledge forward and to work
together with other people that might
not be from your field or even from your
walk of life to
try and create a better world